for those who have it all a submarine
for yacht
owners priced at a mere
$3.45 million when you dive in one of
these Subs the acrylic H literally
disappears around you so it looks as if
you're floating in the water column and
that provides guests with that wow
factor that Yachts really want to
provide these
days it was just one of the high-end
gadgets on display at jubai Big Boys
Toys exhibition
is is a show of of uniqueness and luxury
of course no boys toys event would be
complete without soup top sports
cars and for the party animal there's
this a $400 a Time Limo complete with
dance floor and Wi-Fi it's got a touch
screen in there uh you can connect your
own iPads your iPhones uh your tablets
anything like that for commuters
dreaming of the slopes this could prove
a hit a self-balancing skateboard that
makes makes you feel like you're
snowboarding but it's not all high-tech
this push bike is one of the priciest
exhibits coming in at an eyw watering $3
million I painted The Cosmic star
Cruiser art bicycle for my friend Andy
War he's not with us anymore he passed
he passed away in 88 but I always told
it one day I do the most expensive
motorcycle and the most expensive
bicycle in the world so far I've done
them both it's proof that pricey toys
mean big business in Dubai he